hi everyone thanks for joining us
my name is vincent striva i am the
clinical laboratory director
of sherman abrams laboratory which is a
clinical laboratory
based in brooklyn new york our patient
population serves the greater new york
city
metropolitan area and surrounding
counties
and the largest patient populations we
have are in
the boroughs of brooklyn and queens
in manhattan and so today i'm going to
talk to you a little bit about covid19
particularly
i want to try and focus a little bit on
the role of
antigen testing today and where i see
antigen testing sort of moving in the
near future
so i will not um belabor too much in
terms of background because i think that
stars coke ii is something that a lot of
people are thinking about and sort of
have
a relatively good background on
but i will sort of remind everyone that
the first laboratory confirmed case
of stars cove 2 in the united states was
back in january of this year
in washington state and in the
intervening
year basically uh cyrus co2 as we know
has spread to become
a worldwide pandemic and as of
november 3rd 47 million people worldwide
have
tested positive for stars cove 2
resulting in 1.21 million worldwide
deaths
and the picture in the united states is
equally grim on
nearly 9.5 million u.s cases and over
320
000 u.s debts so our laboratory is
located in brooklyn which is in the
state of new york so i will talk a
little bit about
new york state and you'll hear a little
bit later about some
new york state testing recommendations
for antigen testing as well
so in new york state we got started on
this pandemic
very early on so the
the biggest impact we felt in the months
of march and april
when we started and had our largest
ongoing outbreak
but since since testing began in new
york in march
the state has tested nearly 15 million
people by
pcr with over half a million positive
test results and unfortunately 33 000
people who have died of covid 19 in your
state
so as of this recording the
most recently available numbers just to
show you a snapshot of where new york
state testing is right now
are from the 1st of november so as
of that date new york is testing roughly
100
000 individuals by pcr every day
with a positivity rate in the range of
around one and a half
to two percent um and if you look at
this map you'll see
that the darker shades particularly the
reds in the southern part of the state
are show where the largest
number of positive cases have been
reported in the state
and this makes sense because if you know
anything about the geography of new york
you'll know
that those darker colors correspond to
the larger metropolitan
or urban centers in the state so our
laboratory is in brooklyn
uh which is right at uh the southern
part of this map here
in one of the reddest zones so we've had
a large number
of coded cases that we have
tested and reported
so new york has done a lot to emphasize
the importance of testing particularly
pcr testing
and one of the the biggest pushes from
state and local health officials and
government has been
accessibility of testing new york has
set up testing centers throughout the
state to provide
anyone who wants a test in new york the
ability to get a test
and one of the one of the pushes that
the
state and local officials are making are
that pcr results should be available
within 48 hours of specimen collection
so that
they are more easily able to guide
treatment and are more clinically useful
so this aggressive screening strategy is
sort of depicted in this
chart from the department of health so
if
basically in the blue bars it plots the
total number of
uh coveted test results performed in the
state
from when we started testing in march
through the most recent date that date
as the data is available basically
through the beginning of november
and you can see a very large increase
particularly starting over the summer
in the number of test results tests
performed
in new york state perhaps a little bit
understated just because of the
magnitude of the bars
is what you see in yellow over here um
which is the positive positivity rate
so you can see that in march and april
when we had our peak
stars cove 2 activity that there are
significant numbers of positive test
results
unfortunately since then in the state
due to
public health measures social distancing
etc we've been able to sort of flatten
that curve
so stars cove to testing um
in hindsight now we have the benefit of
knowing more than we did
in march when the outbreak hit us in in
new york
um so now for example we know that
perhaps predictably um
viral rna becomes detectable by pcr
or a few days before the onset of
symptoms so those are the magenta and
blue lines on this chart so pcr is
detectable in
nasopharyngeal or sputum specimens
basically
most often by the time of symptom onset
and a few within this certainly a few
days
later however what you'll also notice is
unlike some
other respiratory diseases
it seems like viral or at least rna
positivity by pcr seems to linger a bit
in some instances more than two weeks
after the onset of symptoms and i'll
talk a little bit
more about this later but what i just
want to point out here
is if you compare the blue and magenta
lines which are the pcr
the presence of rna by pcr to the red
line which is the recovery of
basically infectious viral particles by
culture you will see that pcr remains
positive
long after virus is no longer
culturable from a clinical specimen
one thing we didn't know certainly at
the beginning of the pandemic that we
know now
is the sort of unusual antibody response
that we see
to sars cove ii um so generally with a
viral illness you would expect
an initial igm antibody response to then
be followed
by an igg antibody response some days
later
however if you look here in the purple
and green
hatched lines you can see that igm
and igg antibodies for stars cove two
tend to rise and peak at roughly
the same time um and so currently the
testing recommendations don't really
indicate any preference for one antibody
over the other
in terms of of indicating a
recent prior infection
um so
let's go back now to what i was saying
before so we are a clinical laboratory
in brooklyn
um and in march our outbreak started
here in new york
and providers were across the area were
just
scrambling to bring on
some kind of diagnostic testing for
patients
who they thought were either exposed to
or had
sars cove too so our laboratory brought
on pcr testing for sars cove 2 in march
and this next slide shows you our pcr
testing results
so you may be a little bit surprised to
see you know i just will point out that
each month we test
roughly 25 000 um sars co2
pcr specimens so you may be surprised to
see here we started testing in march
and in march the month of march when our
outbreak
was happening here in new york we had a
nearly 60 percent
pcr positivity rate which is truly
almost unfathomable it was a very hard
time to run a clinical laboratory
in in the city of new york um
and you'll see we also that continued
the high positivity rate into april
um where it was over 30 and that's
because
the first half of the month was
basically also very high 50 to 60
percent
and then in the second half of april um
once new york
had sort of uh instituted
more strict shutdown and um quarantined
procedures and
matt encouraged mask wearing and other
social distancing
uh procedures we were effectively able
to flatten the curve in new york which
you can see
we did a very good job of for the summer
months with
very low positivity rates through the
summer
those rates now are maybe a little bit
higher with back to school
but still we're not seeing anything
close
to what we saw at the beginning of this
pandemic
in march and april
so i've told you that we began
pcr testing in march and providers
saw the results of their patients pcr
tests
however in march access to pcr
testing reagents consumables
instrumentation
was very limited not just at our
laboratory but
laboratories across the country and so
providers were not able to test everyone
who
they wanted to test
so naturally seeing
the high 60 positivity rate for pcr
providers wondered well how can i
determine which of my patients
may have previously had
sars sars co2 infection and either been
unable to access
a pcr test or either had it before pcr
testing was even
available widespread and so naturally
providers are used to thinking about
antibodies and so they
immediately started reaching out to
laboratories across the region looking
for
sars code 2 antibody assays and in march
and the beginning of april
there were no fda approved or no fda
eua emergency use authorization
approved antibody tests for
covin however what there were and what
the fda did allow
was manufacturers to distribute antibody
tests
to providers and laboratories
without going through the eua process
because they had a backlog and they
didn't want to be accused i guess
of of hindering testing testing and
access to testing
so effectively what this wound up doing
was
flooding the market with quite frankly
tests that were not
well tested verified tests that
we could not confirm the accuracy of but
providers were desperate and so they
began using many of these tests
lateral flow immunoassays that just
uh you know came to them from mysterious
manufacturers
um and they use these assays at the
point of care
um to make clinical decisions and
i think that very very good many of
these assays were
clinically useless to be quite honest
fortunately in april a number of
manufacturers
got fda eua for
antibody tests more reliable
reviewed by the fda and had received
emergency use authorization
and so our laboratory decided to go with
one of these
fda eua authorized tests that was one of
the first
to market and that was the diasporin
sars code ii igg assay which
detects antibodies against the cor
covid2 uh sars cove to
spike protein which is probably one of
the more immunogenic proteins
by the from the virus so we started
testing in april
of uh this year and every month we test
about 30 000 patients
for antibodies and you'll see in april
and may
our data showed a 45 antibody positivity
rate
from everyone that we tested in the
laboratory
and many of these people were people who
were never symptomatic
but because the prevalence in new york
city
and in particularly in brooklyn and
queens was so high
a very large proportion of our patient
population
tested positive for covet igg antibodies
and this has been fairly consistent we
haven't had
a huge number as you saw in the previous
slide of new infections over the summer
so most of these positive antibody tests
that were seen in september and october
are most likely patients who were
infected during our outbreak
in march and april who still have
itg antibodies
so one thing we did look at uh early in
the course of this pandemic in our
laboratory
um in the month of april was how
um antibody responses were
sort of broken up by age group and so
that's here on the
left panel if you take a look and you
can see that for us
in the month of april the antibody
positive prevalence rate
was relatively consistent for most age
groups except for
a little bump on the left where we see a
slightly higher
slightly higher but significantly higher
uh positivity rate in
patients let's say between the ages of
10 and 28 years of age and this was
interesting to us
because these were patients who we know
do not experience
um usually do not experience ill effects
from a size cove to infection in terms
of symptoms or
or outcomes but it does seem based on
this data
that they do have robust antibody
responses
and make igg antibodies regardless of
that
or maybe because of that again we don't
we don't know for sure at this time
one other thing we looked at here on the
right is we worked with a provider at an
urgent care facility
who worked with us to grade patients
as they came into his facility based on
their symptoms
with zero on the x-axis representing
asymptomatic patients and a four on the
x-axis
representing the most critically ill
patients patients who required either
hospitalization or oxygen support
and and here in this figure we look at
the antibody response in terms of a
semi-quantitative antibody response
uh using the deosorin liaison igg assay
the response of the igg to that symptom
severity and we see in both males and
females
a relation between increased symptoms
severity
and increased levels of of igg
antibodies which maybe
says that more critically ill patients
make have a stronger antibody response
again there's still more to be studied
here
but when we publish this in the journal
diet of diagnostic microbiology and
infectious diseases in
in may it was sort of new information
for everyone
so i want to transition a little bit
from the laboratory to the point of care
because i think that during a pandemic
such as this
point of care testing is very important
uh people are walking into
urgent cares and they want results
available to them before they
leave for the day basically within 20-30
minutes
so there are a number of point-of-care
tests that have received
fda emergency use authorization
including uh one eua point of care
antibody test
and the other 14 split evenly between
point of care molecular and antigen
tests
the point of care molecular tests tend
to be
um hard for facilities to come by
reagents consumables and test
instrumentation is short so the vast
majority of point of care testing
that's performed today in the clinic is
antigen testing and
the three of the the most common point
of care antigen tests
are the kaidel sophia which was the
first to receive fda eua
the bd variety and the abbott binax now
i mentioned a bit earlier just to point
out
that eua and eun are not necessarily
created equally again the fda allowed
for manufacturers to release tests onto
the market
without going through the emergency use
authorization approval process
which is not to say that all eun tests
are
inherently worse than an eua test just
that there's less
oversight of them
so as these sort of point-of-care
antigen testing
kits came onto the market we began to
hear reports that
they weren't very good their sensitivity
was bad
you know there are a lot of false
negatives false positives no one really
had a very good sense of
what was going on and so these are just
two popular press headlines some
recently
you know coronavirus antigen tests quick
and cheap but too often wrong
a rapid virus test falters and people
without symptoms
study fines and so uh you we're seeing a
lot in the popular press
especially about the performance of
antigen tests um
and it's not always necessarily the most
accurate source of information or at
least not the most accurate
interpretation of
what i believe the data actually show
that being said we also see sort of the
other side of this
so just just the other day we i heard
that slovakia has
intends to test its entire population
using uh
antigen testing which i think is is
pretty neat so we'll see i'm sure
um i'm sure we'll see in the coming in
the coming weeks
how that shakes out
um but in order to talk about you know
the accuracy and sensitivity of uh pcr
testing
i uh of antigen testing i think first
we need to talk about
the pcr testing which is sort of the
gold standard now
and i think we need to talk about pcr
testing in terms of sensitivity versus
clinical utility
so i've just summarized a review of 29
studies that look
at pcr and compare it to viral culture
which if you
again if you remember from an earlier
slide
viral culture is generally a measure of
infectious viral particles with the
ideal
the idea being that culture negative
samples
are are non-infectious
so if there's no if you're not able to
grow a virus
in culture from a patient a patient
sample
then you are not like that patient is
not likely to be able to pass
infectious urine on to someone else
so looking at a number of studies and
it always is difficult to compare one
manufacturer's pcr
assay to another but
generally the consensus is that for pcrs
with ct values greater than
30 so weak positive pcrs
there is limited to no culture growth
seen from these specimens so
high positive pcrs generally do not
correlate with the ability to recover
virus from a specimen
which we can then say implies that high
positive pcr-positive specimen specimens
don't correlate to infectivity
necessarily and so why is this the case
um i mentioned also earlier we seem to
now
know that rna shedding for sars co2
lasts a bit longer than we would have
originally expected
so we generally see rna shedding 14 days
and beyond past the onset of symptoms
whereas we don't really see positive
viral culture results beyond about 8
days or so
from
from symptoms
um and so this sort of brings us to uh
you know the joys of running the
clinical laboratory during the global
pandemic
uh in march we were when we first
brought pcr testing online
i got calls every day from clients
wanting to make sure that the pcr test
we were running
was a good pcr test that was sensitive
enough to catch
everything and now sort of as
providers are wrapping their heads
around the implications of
high ct value samples and how they
relate to
rna shedding versus positive culture
results they're now starting to call and
ask
well is maybe your lab's pcr test overly
sensitive
you know i've even had patients call the
lab and say oh i read in the new york
times about ct values
can you tell me about the ct values in
your laboratory uh so you know
there's a lot going on here and a lot
left for us to learn
and unpack about uh pcr testing so i'm
just gonna talk a little bit briefly
about it
but again it won't be a comprehensive
discussion for sure so this is a figure
from
the new england journal of medicine by a
group out of boston
and they sort of compare two
hypothetical tests
so you see that they list the bottom
line is a high analytic sensitivity test
which they're calling a pcr
and the top line is a low analytic
sensitivity test which i
i think you can think of as sort of an
antigen test and the argument here that
the authors are making
is that these high analytic tests these
pcrs we know that resources are limited
tests are limited we can't test serially
a patient
every day so you may because you only
get decreased frequency of testing
you may miss the infectious period of
that patient so for example if you look
at the high analytic
sensitivity line you have an initial
test which is negative before that
patient
has made any virus which is fine that
patient is negative that patient is not
making any virus
but then because of lack of testing or
whatnot by the time a patient gets a
result
after they have symptoms they're in a
post-infectious period
so they're in that period after culture
is no longer positive
however because the pcr test has a high
sensitivity
they've got a pipe they've got a
positive pcr result so the question
remains and i'm not going to answer this
question
certainly but as a provider what do you
do with
a positive pcr result like this from
what we're calling a post-infectious
patient now contrast this to the line
that's labeled low analytic sensitivity
where the argument is if this is a
readily available test that you can just
pump out
thousands and thousands and thousands
every day of then you can test the
patient
every day and you'll get a negative
result four days in a row until that
patient finally has a viral load that's
clinically significant and then you'll
get a positive test result and you have
caught that patient
in that infection infectious window
so again i think the importance here is
a balance of
clinical sensitivity with clinical
utility
is a more sensitive
assay necessarily better
and then another up question that's up
in the air is does antigen testing
capture the majority of clinically
relevant cases and again i think that
there's no one-size-fits-all answer for
that and it will depend on
the proper evaluation of antigen assays
as they continue to be
released on the market
however i just want to just spend a very
short amount of time
saying that there is good evidence that
anti-antigen testing
correlates with um
viral load so here's a paper from the
international journal of infectious
diseases
and you can see very clearly that sarsko
to antigen response on the y-axis
or antigen level on the y-axis is
linearly and directly correlated with
sars cove
ii viral load um on the on the x-axis
um and also out of a group in the
netherlands published as a pre-print
they look at three
um antigen tests with differing
sensitivities
tests a b and c the vertical dashed
lines
these uh different tests test of these
three uh
so on the x-axis is the limit of
detection basically or the viral load of
the sample
so you can see that test a is more
sensitive than test b
is more sensitive than test c and they
look at
how these tests how good of a job these
tests do
with calling samples that are also
positive by culture and again remember
the idea is
that in order for uh for you to consider
a patient as infectious you have to sort
of
accept that they will be piece culture
positive they may not
uh necessarily be
pcr negative at that point um and so you
can see that
um as the sensitivity decreases actually
you get a bit of a better correlation
to positive cultures than for the more
sensitive tests and this is not
obviously to say that you want to throw
sensitivity out the window
but i think it is important to
at least understand this and balance
sensitivity versus clinical utility
for what it is worth the state of new
york
has recommendations for testing using
antigens
or antigen testing and they are slightly
different depending on whether the
patient is from a symptomatic on the
left or an asymptomatic
patient population on the right
basically in both cases they
tell you that a positive antigen test is
deficient
that patient has covid and they
can they should quarantine for
the appropriate amount of time and then
the difference is how they recommend
dealing with a negative antigen test so
in a symptomatic population
they recommend immediately following a
negative antigen test
with a confirmatory rt-pcr and if that
rtbcr is positive
obviously the patient uh may or may not
be
infectious again think about sensitivity
versus clinical
utility however the recommendation right
now from the state of new york is
to quarantine that patient because of
the positive pcr test
in an asymptomatic patient population
they actually are a little bit less
strong
about their recommendation for pc
following a negative antigen test
with pcr testing they may recommend it
but they're not going to i don't think
enforce it
so this sort of brings me to um
my next slide which is um
using antigen testing in a diagnostic
setting
so i use diagnostic setting to mean
testing of symptomatic patients
and using antigen testing in a screening
setting and i use a screening setting
to mean testing asymptomatic patients so
for example in
um a mass back to school drive
where you want to test a school of a
thousand children
you don't expect them to be positive i
would call this the screening test
and so there have been some studies that
look at the sensitivity of antigen
testing versus pcr
in diagnostic testing uh so in
symptomatic patients
and we see a relatively good up to 90
sensitivity versus pcr in symptomatic
patients which i think is pretty
good um but when we test in asymptomatic
patients for a screening population
we see a much poorer sensitivity some
studies report as low
as 30 versus pcr but again the question
is
does this matter are these clinically
relevant infections i think that's still
something
that moving forward we're going to have
to wrap our heads around
and think about
however i just want to point out one
additional reason of why i think antigen
testing
will be uh important moving forward
so i think pcr testing will remain the
gold standard because
it is a very sensitive methodology
however
if we understand that sometimes more
sensitive is not necessarily better
then i think we have a place for antigen
testing particularly in light
of a recent survey by the association of
molecular pathology amp
who surveyed clinical labs throughout
the country
and inquired about testing
shortages and so you know
many laboratories at least a third of
laboratories
report limited access to either pcr
testing platforms
pcr reagents rna extraction reagents
or consumables for pcr testing
and this has resulted in the majority of
laboratories
running more three or more methods for
covid pcr
which is certainly a burden on the
laboratory
um and also not necessarily ideal for
serial monitoring of patients
who may be tested on different platforms
even within the same laboratory
um one other just quick note is that
these shortages do not just impact
coded testing so because of changes to
supply chains and manufacturing by
manufacturers to ramp up
production of covert related tests
they've had to
oftentimes decrease production of
non-covert related tests
so we've seen significant allocation
issues with reagents for things like std
testing
or other infectious disease testing
viral loads etc
so there are impacts to pc
mass pcr testing that are rippling
through clinical laboratories now
and i do think that if we can transition
some of this testing to antigen testing
hopefully some of these
issues will be mitigated
but to do this we sort of need to make
sure and i just want to end here
by saying what i'm hoping for in terms
of
widespread antigen testing we have to
make sure
that the antigen tests we use are
properly vetted
and they're used appropriately to
replace pcr testing
so for example if you have a highly
symptomatic patient
you probably are will do fine testing
them
by antigen you can save a pcr test
however in order to really know this i
think we need to do a proper
comparison of any antigen test to pcr
and culture to make sure that we have
that right balance between
um sensitivity and clinical relevance
and i do think that at this point the
best
the best location for things like this
to happen are in
clea labs and not at point of care
facilities i think that
just inherently laboratories are better
equipped to
properly evaluate these antigen tests
and i think one important thing moving
forward
will be alternative specimen types and
transport medias
so we have shortages of
vtms and utms we have shortages of
nasopharyngeal swabs
so the ability to test for antigen
in swabs and saline or in saliva
specimens
i think will be key to moving laboratory
testing
to the next stage and where this
pandemic needs to go
and then finally i think that we really
need to have
some high throughput solutions um
and move away from sort of these low
throughput
point of care settings into a high
throughput testing platform
at the clinical laboratory so
thank you for spending this time with me
i would like to thank the wonderful team
of techs that work for me in the
laboratory
particularly led by our lab supervisor
rihanna akhtar
as well as some others in the laboratory
josh ben and ike who have been
instrumental in sort of keeping the
management of the laboratory under
control during this very difficult time
and thanks to uh nelson hayem who
um was our sort of clinical provider who
who helped us with data for our paper
that i talked about on one slide
um and then finally i just would like to
end with a important reminder
please wear your masks
thanks and i'm happy to answer any
questions by email